[Music]  the Taylor Swift have a new man multiple  reports are linking the 27 year old  singer to British actor Joe Allen the 26  year old most recently appeared in Billy  Lynn's long halftime walk he's trying to  get through the damn long piece et has  reached out to both of their reps Jose  had no comment  Taylor's been reclusive in recent months  a source told et in April she's been  laying low in Nashville working on her  upcoming album check out these pics the  blonde beauty touching down in Music  City on Saturday and later leaving her  mother's home a new album and possibly a  new man we think 2017 looks pretty darn  good on t-swift  do you think Taylor and Joe are heating  up as a new couple tweet us at ET now  [Music]  you